الحركه شبه مشلوله في محطه لندن بريدج
للقطارات غادر السائقون والعمال مواقعهم
مدربين عن العمل 48 ساعه مطالبين بزياده
اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم من بين كل خمسه
قطارات يعمل واحد فقط واوقات الانتظار
زادت الى اقصى حد
جئت من جنوب لندن استغرقت الرحله نصف ساعه
لم يكن الامر سيئا جدا ولكن القطار مزدحم
للغايه اعتقد انني محظوظه
يتسبب اضطرابات كبيره وهذا ليس جيد لاي
احد خاصه اننا نريد رؤيه عائلتنا تقله
منذ الصيف الماضي والذي ياخذ منحا تصاعديا
في ظل العجزي عن تلبيه مطالب المطربين لكن
المشهد هنا ليس استثناء المعيشه يشمل
الجميع والاضرابات تنتقل الى مختلف
القطاعات
العدوى وصلت الى المستشفيات حيث سيكون
الاضراب اشد ايلاما
الممرضون سيقلصون خدماتهم الى ادنى حد
ممكن خلال يومين في اضراب هو الاكبر من
نوعه في تاريخ القطاع
الصحينا وتواصلنا مع الحكومه وفعلنا كل
شيء بشان سوء ظروفنا لكنهم لم يستمعون لنا
والاضراب هو ملاذنا الاخير كي نحصل على
زياده ونحافظ على طواقيمنا ونحميه مرضانه
دائره الاحتجاجات تتسع لترجع على جلده
الشهر الجاري ممتلئه بالاضطرابات التي
تشمل ايضا قوه حرس الحدود في المطارات
وسائقي الاسعافات وعمال البريد
تروح الحكومه بالاستعانه بالجيش لسد العجز
في القطاعات الحيويه لكن ذلك لا يزيد
النقابات الا عنادا خصوصا مع دخول فصل
الشتاء واشتداد وقع ازمه غلاء المعيشه
محمد المدهون الجزيره لندن